قال جون بولت ، مستشار الأمن القومي بشكل
أساسي ، إن إيران هي المسؤولة
عن كل هذا الآن ، فإن أسبابه وراء
ذلك معقدة بعض الشيء ، كما يقول ،
لأن الإسرائيليين كانوا
يستهدفون المناطق الموالية لإيران في سوريا والتي
تصادف وجودها حول اللاذقية التي هي
أيضًا مع  القواعد الجوية الروسية ،
وبالتالي فإن إيران مسؤولة عن
كل ما حدث بعد ذلك ، من
الواضح أن الجيش السوري قام
بطريق الخطأ بإسقاط تلك
الطائرة الروسية معتقدًا أنها كانت تطلق النار على
الإسرائيليين ، ومن الواضح أن الروس غير
راضين عن هذه الإجابة على الإطلاق ،
فهم يوجهون أصابع الاتهام إلى
إسرائيل.  لنفترض أن طائرة إسرائيلية
استخدمت بشكل أساسي الطائرة الروسية
كغطاء وضع تلك الطائرة الروسية في
خط النار الآن نتيجة لذلك ، فإن
الروس يضعون
نظام الدفاع الجوي المطوّر هذا المسمى s-300
ويقولون أن الاختلاف الكبير مع s  -300
هي حقيقة أنه يمكن التمييز بسهولة
بين الطائرات الصديقة وغير الودية
في السماء  لذلك ، لديها مدى أطول في
نظام رادار أكثر تطوراً بكثير ،
كما يقول الروس إنهم بحاجة إلى كل هذا
للتأكد من أن طائراتهم لن يتم
إسقاطها في المستقبل ، لكن
بالطبع تقول الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل أن
هذا شيء مهم  التصعيد في تلك
المنطقة ، ومن الواضح أنه لا يعرض
الطائرات الإسرائيلية للخطر فحسب ، بل يعرض أيضًا
الطائرات الأمريكية إذا كانت تعمل في السماء
فوق سوريا ، نعلم من تقرير باربرا
ستار الخاص بنا.  تبحث الآن
في هذا النظام الجديد
وتعتقد بشكل أساسي أن الطائرات الأمريكية
يمكن أن تبقى خارج نطاق s-300 ،
لكنها بالتأكيد قد تجعل المناورة
فوق سوريا وحول سوريا أكثر
صعوبة بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة ، وكما سمعنا
هناك من جون  بولتون يعتقد أن
هذا يمكن أن يكون تصعيد كبير
ديف